good morning Dan how are you I am good
dan how are you
I'm spectacular but I do have questions
about the OJ Simpson parole hearing
yesterday well let me ask you what came
to mind what's the one question that is
still left unanswered for you with what
happened yesterday well there was a was
a parole board member who decided on the
day of the parole board Oh J meeting to
do where a Kansas City Chiefs tie to the
parole board I'm baffled I'm okay did he
just think it was a football-themed
parole board like what if he had worn a
bill someone who was a rival of the
bills like imagine if you're going for
parole and you were Buffalo Bill and he
shows up with the Patriots or a Jets tie
I mean you're like what you fix is
outrageous did you get the feeling that
Oh Jay still thinks he can talk himself
out of any situation because I'm
watching yesterday and it just felt like
the longer he talked the deeper he got
in but he thought he could charm you and
I don't know if it worked yesterday but
he did that yesterday well to a more
serious point of what I was getting at
is I think that this thing was the state
accompli is the parole board did not
like all the attention they just wanted
out day out and they didn't want to have
to do this again in another year or
whenever it up again for parole so he
was going to get out but look I did a
story earlier in a week talking of OJ's
former lawyers other lawyers everyone
says the same thing there is one golden
rule a one word golden rule when it
comes to a Parole Board hearing and that
is remorse go in say I did it I'm sorry
I'll never do it again
I've learned from my mistakes this is
terrible Oh Jay gets in there and starts
reaaargh you in the case ah you know
he's going I'm sorry I don't complain
but you know it really wasn't that bad
of a deal and he had people texting me
you know he's killing himself he's going
to he's going to blow this thing
the key here was that the Nevada
Department of Corrections was like
enough nine years we've dealt with this
guy it really wasn't that serious of a
crime just get him out of here so I
think OJ was getting out anyway but he
nearly talked his way back in I think he
still thinks he's holding court at a
restaurant or a bar or banquet somewhere
and everyone's going to love all of his
jokes he some of his lines are
absolutely outrageous I mean he
literally said is a direct quote ah you
know I have basically lived a
conflict-free life now sure other than
the string of domestic violence the
double homicide trial the two times
you've been incarcerated in this armed
robbery other than that other than
basically Dan basically I mean some of
the lines he was saying and in the
parole when the parole board's not
challenging them on that it's not like
they don't first up they have his
disciplinary record in this whole case
file but everybody knows this stuff
about OJ Simpson he was just going to
get out and and that's it so it's really
about what kind of life so J want to
live from here on out well that leads me
to the next question how short is that
leash with OJ on parole well there will
be you know certain things again you
know drink in excess I'm not really sure
I you know he'd have to probably get
nailed on a DUI or something like that
there's there's different things but he
is expected to move to the st.
Petersburg Florida area where three of
his kids kind of put down roots is I
thought his oldest daughter
Arnel was there she gave probably the
most serious and heartfelt of all the
but it will actually wasn't even close
she did a better job for OJ than OJ or
his attorney did in just pleading to say
look let this guy out you know it's been
sad for us he's a seven-year-old man and
all that the question is you know OJ
would sit there and say hey look I just
want to be with my friends my family I
want to I want to stay out of the
spotlight and you go okay that's exactly
what you should say and his attorney
saying hey maybe there's a blog in the
street maybe he's going to do some
webcast
like what you're the attorney you're
supposed to be helping him here um I
don't know are we going to get reality
shows and OJ showing up a memorabilia
signings I mean he is infamous now and
it's been a long time since the double
homicide and there's a lot of people
that weren't alive or remember that and
so you know it can bring out the
absolute worst in American culture when
everyone's celebrating OJ and you know
if he's at restaurant you know he's out
on the town people are going to flock to
him and that is the intoxicating OJ
situation when he can charm people it
kind of got him involved in such a
ridiculous antics like you know this
underground memorabilia market where
he's got himself back in trouble so I
think everyone would hope that a look he
served his time on this and this is how
the system works and you hope he's
spending it you know playing golf and
hanging out with his grandkids but kind
of hard to see them be a pension year
down in Florida going to the early bird
special and just you know hanging out at
the Muni Dan Wetzel joining us yahoo
sports national columnist well we have a
little bit of time the Hugh Freeze
situation at Ole Miss I know you wrote
about that what's the one question you
have that kind of is still looming over
this well here's the situation Hugh
Freeze you know back in 2016 the NCAA
drops this notice of allegations get all
this cheating at Ole Miss but it's
hidden from the public and Hugh Freeze
and old myths decide we're going to say
we're going to tell a bunch of reporters
and media members and broadcasters that
most of the allegations involve the
previous coaching staff and that was it
were led by Houston Nutt and it's not
about Hugh Freeze and there's nothing to
worry about they were trying to spin
that lie to settle things down and keep
their nashit their recruiting class
which is about the sign in about three
four weeks and early in early February
so they pitched that lie and you know
what's a positive for Hugh Freeze hey
he's not a cheater these stories come
out is it you know the eagle
opposite reaction is against houston
nutt oh he's the cheater use the notes
as I didn't do it and eventually last
spring in 17 when the notice of
allegations the whole case becomes
public the violations are almost nothing
to do with Houston not they're
everything to do with you free so
houston nutt says you know you guys
slandered me here
I want my good name back I want an
apology and I and Ole Miss to set the
record straight and have a have a press
conference saying we were all on this
cue freeze refused to back down he
refused to do the right thing and
apologized after crushing houston nutt
so nut has a lawyer very aggressive
lawyer they file a lawsuit and they go
through his phone records to try to
prove that he's calling reporters and
spinning this thing and they're in that
investigation they only get six days of
phone records and in there is this one
phone call one minute and the lawyer
looks up what's this number and it turns
out to be associated with an escort
down in Florida and boom Hugh Freeze is
busted he then says hey I it's just a
wrong number I miss dial there's only
one minute Ole Miss and says I we're
going to look through every single call
you've ever made and now
last night they say that was a very
disturbing and consistent pattern of
behavior here when you have that you
look back and say Jesus you just did the
right thing and apologized to advisor to
the other than apology yeah you're out
what enjoy your weekend in you know you
deserve some time off after the complete
bad quite a week sharper shark verse
helps on Sunday night yeah get back to
real sporting action yes thank you Dan
hey Dan Dan Wetzel Yahoo Sports national
columnist yeah it's Michael Phelps
versus the shark coming up on Sunday
night the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience